Good evening everyone. Uh I now call to
order this August 11th, 2025 meetings of
uh city council committees. Uh we'll
begin with the roll call of members. Mr.
Harris, would you please call the role?
>> Yes, Madam President.
>> Mr. Med,
>> here.
>> Mr. Roya,
>> Mr. Glee,
>> here. Miss Craig
>> here,
>> Mr. Hirs
>> and President Baker
>> here.
>> We We are once again working with uh
temporary technology, so I'll ask
everyone for their uh forgiveness if we
get some squeaking or popping in the
microphones. We'll do our best to try to
use them one at a time. We're not
usually going at that rapid pace like we
are for roll call. Uh so hopefully that
will not continue to be an issue. Uh
we'll begin with the approval of the
July 1st, 2025 committee meeting
minutes.
>> Motion to approve.
>> Second.
>> We have a motion and a second.
Counselors, any comments on the minutes?
>> Hearing none. Mr. Harris.
>> Mr. M.
>> I.
>> Mr. Royer.
>> Mr. Gleas.
>> I.
>> Mr. Craig.
>> Hi.
>> M.
>> Mr. Hersh.
>> Hi.
>> President Bacon.
>> Hi. Right. Uh we will now go to the
personnel committee councelor
colleagues.
>> Thank you, Madam President. The
personnel committee has um 11 items on
the agenda for tonight. And the first
item is the nomination of Katie Shifflet
for appointment to the downtown
investment district authority.
I don't know if Katie is here. Would you
please uh go to the microphone, please?
Hello. Okay.
>> Good evening. Thank you for being here
tonight. Would you please introduce
yourself and tell us why you want to
serve on the board?
>> Sure. Um, can you guys hear me? Okay.
Uh, my name is Katie Shifflet. I'm with
Somayas Properties. Um, I would love to
join this board. I not only work
downtown, but I also live downtown. I
have my entire life. So, I think it
would be an amazing opportunity to join
this board and really um
help with everything that the DID is
involved with. Between safety, cleanup,
outreach, I think all the things that
they have done in the past few years
have been great. I have an opportunity
to see firsthand from both a residential
and a commercial side um the different
things that the city has done, how it's
grown over the years from something
simple to something extraordinary. and I
think that I could be a great asset to
the board itself.
>> Thank you. Are there any comments or
questions from other members of the
committee?
>> Uh thank you councelor colleagues and
thank you for your willingness to serve.
Uh my only question is how do you see
the role of uh the downtown investment
district and um uh diversifying
opportunities for business owners in the
downtown?
>> Um
thank you for your question. Uh, I think
the biggest thing when it comes to
diversifying downtown, um, equal
opportunity all over. I think that
there's not enough people that realize
different things that you can do
downtown as a business owner. I think
that also having the ability to be on
this board will hopefully help to give a
voice to other people as well. Like I
said, I've grown up in Lancaster and
I've seen different businesses come in
and go. Um, and now being on another
side of property management and leasing
with the commercial side, I've seen, you
know, businesses not do that great and
businesses do amazing. I think that
having the ability to see both of those
sides and be on a board like the DID
would be a great asset um, in helping to
bring different businesses through. Um,
I think everybody can agree that we have
all different types of people here. We
have all different types of businesses
here. And I think
whoever else wants to come and kind of
share their business and their talent
and things like that would be great. So
>> other questions or comments from members
of the committee
hear? None from council
from the public.
>> Thank you very much.
>> Thank you so much. Now I'll make a
motion to move this nomination to our
next console meeting on August on August
12.
>> Second.
>> All in favors?
>> I.
>> The next item is the nomination of Molly
Kirkov for reappointment to the signing
commission
and uh no meanies for reappointment are
not required to attend the meeting. So,
are there any comments or questions from
members of the committee and council?
>> Council Cle,
>> just a comment. Councelor Klest, uh,
Molly uh serves as the the leader of the
L the public art uh in in Lancaster City
as a city employee and so she would be
the employee member of the SIM
commission and had served faithfully in
that role previously.
>> Thank you, Council President.
Any comments from the public?
I'll make a motion to move this
nomination to our next console meeting
on August 12.
>> Second.
>> All in favors?
>> I. We continue with three nominations
to the public art advisory board.
Nomination of Cisava Tong Vanong,
Barry Konoser, Rachel Feming Hills
and those uh individuals
serve currently serve on the board and
they have expressed their willingness to
be reappointed.
Any questions or comments from members
of the committee?
Councelor Kix, I'll just make a quick
comment um that I have the honor of
serving on the public art advisory board
with Rachel Barry and Cis Ole um on the
public art advisory board and I just uh
they all do a really good job, all bring
good ideas um and so I definitely think
uh they're an asset on that board.
>> Thank you councelor for your comment.
Any other comments or questions from
members of the committee, from council,
from the public?
>> Now, I'll make a motion to move these
nominations to our next council meeting
on August 12th.
>> Second.
>> All in favors?
>> I
>> I The next item is the nomination of
Jean Werts for reappointment to the
Lancaster Higher Education Authority.
And uh there isn't much to say about
this reappointment. I'll open up for
questions or comments from members of
the committee
from council
from the public.
I'll move this nomination to our next
council meeting on August 12th.
>> All in favors? I
we continue with five nominations
to the board of plumbing examiners
and the nominees are Eric Weiss, Barry
Solder, Shaunway,
Trent Meyers.
All those four individuals are
are the nominees for the appointment to
the board of plumbing plumbing
examiners. And we also have a nomination
for appointment
to the board of plumbing examiners and
the nominee is Mason Solder.
And are there any questions or comments
about those nominations
from members of the committee?
Is uh is Mason here?
>> Oh yes. So thank you for your
willingness to help. Could you please go
to the microphone, please?
>> Thank you for your willingness to serve.
Could you please introduce yourself and
tell us what motivates you to serve on
the board?
>> Yeah. Um so my name is Mason Solder.
I've been plumbing here in Lancaster
City and
it's
I've been plumbing in Lancaster City and
the surrounding areas for about eight
years now. Um I obtained a master's
license for Lancaster City, uh York,
Reading, Harrisburg.
Um, and it's it's always been a passion
of mine, although it sounds a little
strange in plumbing, but um, it's
something that I absolutely love and
being appointed to be part of the board
is I'm very honored and um, yeah, I will
res respect and have integrity when the
board meets and the all the decisions
that we make.
Uh is there anything particular that you
would like to achieve during your term
on the board?
>> Yeah, there are a lot of codes that u
Lanster City amends every so often. Um
and I have found that it's a little
difficult to get the word out to the
other plumbers. Um, I think it would be
good at least with uh my knowledge and
my connections that I can get that word
out so all the plumbers can come
together and you know successfully
you know plum this place in
>> right
>> um you know so uh yeah but with my
extensive knowledge in the plumbing code
only with the IPC and the local codes um
this is yeah this is really exciting for
me.
Thank you. Um, are there any questions
or comments from members of the
committee?
>> Please, Council H.
>> Just want to say thank you for your
willingness to step up and serve um on
the board. Uh, this is one of those
things that I think uh I'll speak for
myself. I don't always think about these
things day-to-day, but they're really
important. And I'm glad that there are
people that bring this skill set to the
table because it's certainly not mine.
So, thank you for uh for your
willingness to serve.
>> Sure.
>> Other comments or questions
from council,
from the public?
I'll make a motion. Thank you so much.
I'll make a motion to move these
nominations to our next council meeting
on August 12th.
>> Second.
>> All in favors?
>> I.
>> Thank you, Madame President. That
concludes the personal committee. Thank
you very much, Councelor Clicks, and
thank you for all of our volunteer uh
nominees for appointment. Uh the next
item on our agenda this evening is the
finance committee, Councelor Royo.
>> Thank you, Council President. Uh we have
one item on on our agenda this evening
is the 2025 midyear budget report. Uh
and with that, I'll invite Tina
Campbell, uh director of administrative
services.
And councilors, I'll just quickly remind
uh that director Campbell did send these
slides and supporting materials to us in
advance if you wanted to pull them up on
your screens. It would have been before
the regularly scheduled meeting before
we rescheduled this one.
All right. Uh well, thank you for
providing space um to share this report
tonight on the budget. Um since this is
still a new process, I just want to
remind everyone um that we have started
to provide written monthly financial
statements to council. Um and we're
providing this public quarterly report
um as well as those monthly financial
statements. Um, the reporting schedule
is part of the home roll charter. Um,
and I always welcome any feedback for
how to make this process better since
we're still all learning the process
together.
Um, last quarter was the first quarter
that we did this report and I heard from
some people that um, we should have a
visual some visuals for the
presentation. So, I've brought just a
couple of slides tonight. Um, they're
not super exciting. I'm not sure how to
make numbers exciting on on PowerPoint
slides, but um I brought a few. They
they are not comprehensive. Um so I'll
encourage uh council to please refer
back to the reports that um council
president uh just referenced that you
received um you received the monthly
reports on July 21st. Those are the comp
comprehensive reports and then these
reports um were sent out last week as
well. Next slide, please.
So, I'm reporting tonight on the
financial statements which ended on June
30th, 2025. Um, generally we need a few
days to close a month once it is done.
So, the quarterly reports will always
come to the finance committee on the
second month of the following quarter.
It it's generally just about a month
after the quarter closes. This was
delayed a week, but generally that's
about when it is. Um, and because I'm
reporting on the second quarter tonight,
we are at the halfway point for the
year. So obviously revenue and expenses
are not completely even from month to
month, but generally you can use 50% as
the gauge for any line item in these
reports. So in the detailed reports that
you received um ideally we're looking at
50% or more of revenue um that we've
received up to now and 50% or less of
expenses that we've spent.
Next slide, please.
So just as a reminder, here is the full
budget for the year for all of our funds
combined. Um, our combined expenses
equal slightly over 157 million for the
year. And this is for all five of our
funds, the general fund and the four
enterprise funds. As of June 30, we're
running at about 51% of budgeted revenue
over all of the funds and about 39% of
budgeted expenses. So, generally, we're
in line with where we should be at this
time of year. Next slide, please.
Uh, I won't talk much about this slide.
Um hopefully you remember seeing this or
something like this before at our uh
budget hearings in the fall. Uh but this
is the breakdown of revenue in the
general fund. Uh our general fund budget
for revenue is about 79 million for
2025.
This is our largest fund. Um it makes up
almost half of the total combined funds.
So I wanted to show the revenue
breakdown again and I'll show the
expense breakdown in a minute as well.
All right, next slide please.
Uh so for the general fund some
highlights um from the financial
statements for the revenue are um here
as follows. Um so we currently have
about 60% of our budgeted revenue as of
June 30th for the general fund. While
this is great um we do get a lot of our
real estate taxes at the beginning of
the year. So this isn't necessarily
higher than we've projected for the
year. Um we will see that tax amount
gross slower the rest of the year since
there aren't a lot of real estate taxes
left to be paid.
And speaking of real estate taxes, uh
we're running slightly at a slightly
lower rate of real estate taxes
collected this year than as of June 30th
last year. 1.6% might not feel super
significant, but because this is our
largest revenue line, I continue to
watch this line pretty closely. Um 1.6%
is about $520,000.
So it does affect revenue if the rest of
the real estate taxes become too
delinquent.
Um earned income tax continues to come
in almost exactly to projections. Um
which is great to see. Um this is the
the first year that we were looking at
that in income or earned income tax
increase. So it's um nice to see that
coming in as projected.
And there are a few lines that come in
as large payments towards the end of the
year or they come in as one or two
payments throughout the year. And some
of those we haven't received yet. Um, so
I just wanted to note those because
those are not going to be showing that
50%. Um, I've listed here the franchise
fees, um, parking violations, and the
pension state funds. Um, again, all of
those come in the pension state funds
come in at the end of the year.
Franchise fees do as well, and the
parking violations come in in chunks
over the over the course of the year.
Um, these these three lines together
make about f make up about 5.7 million
dollars or about seven 7.2% 2% of the
revenue budget. So that will boost
revenue this fall as those start to come
in as well.
Next slide, please.
So, as with revenue, I just wanted to
quickly show the breakdown in general
fund expenses. Um, as you may remember,
we're anticipating more revenue than
expenses this year. So, we've budgeted
about 76 million in expenses and about
79 million in revenue. The surplus is
budgeted to increase the cash reserves
to a level that gets us closer to what
would be a normal standard of about 20%
of operating income. We likely won't
quite get to that threshold yet, but
we're we're inching our way up there.
Uh, next slide, please.
So, just uh a few highlights of general
fund expenses. General fund expenses are
running at about 40% of the annual
budget. Um, again, this is great. We
want to be lower than 50% or at least
not higher than 50%. Um, staffing
vacancies are driving much of the much
of the savings. Um, though you will see
in some of the bureaus like human
resources, other lines have increased to
cover the work while the vacancies were
being filled. Um, and just as a
reminder, it is allowable to move
expenses within the bureau or department
as long as those total expenses for that
department do not go over the approved
budget. So we watch those movements, but
we al also recognize that budgets are
projections and sometimes one item may
run higher um while others run lower. So
my focus as I review the reports is
generally to look for any high trends uh
within a budget or department. Um and
I'm thankful to say that I I don't see
any of those trends happening right now.
So just a couple of other notes. Um as
on the revenue side, there are some
expenses that come out in one or two
large payments and there are expenses
which might increase in the second half
of the year. Um so the current quarter
that we're in, that's the the third
quarter, um tends to be a higher
overtime quarter for fire um for fire
for the fire department and to a certain
extent police as well. Um so we'll start
to see that increase slightly.
Um, our large debt payments come out in
November, so those lines will jump in
the last quarter of the year. Um, and
the police and fire pension plan
contributions are the same way. And then
just um, another note, many of the IT
contracts actually come out in the
spring. Um, so many of those have come
out. That's a larger line item in our
budget. So I just wanted to note that
it's showing at about 75% spent, but
please know that that's projected and
intended. Uh we anticipate that that
line will stay within budget or actually
might be up slightly under um by the end
of the year
and I think that might be it.
Oh nope not quite.
Um just very quickly a few things about
the enterprise funds. Um so as you
remember we have four enterprise funds.
Storm water, water, uh sewer or
wastewater and trash. Um the stormwater
fund was budgeted at a deficit this
year. Um however, they've kept expenses
at about 30 36% of budget for the year.
So we're actually showing just a slight
surplus in the storm water currently. Uh
which is great to see at this point in
the year. Um and again, we'll keep
watching that. The water fund is also
running slightly lower on expenses, but
we continue to watch this as the cost of
chemicals for water treatment um is
always a big variable for us. Um so that
will we will continue to monitor. Um
sewer is pretty much as expected. Um
sewer revenue is not showing at 50% but
this is due to some bulk um sewer
treatments u that we that we offer that
are larger line items and those come in
later in the year. And then trash um is
almost exactly as projected. Um, so
admittedly the trash fund is an easier
one to project because most of this is
mostly contracted work. You can, you
know, predict it much closer than other
parts of the budget. Um, I say this, but
then you might look at the financial
statement and wonder why we're showing
at 70% of revenue and 80% of expenses or
87% of expenses. And again, this this
has to do with how the payments are
estimated and the invoices are paid. Um,
so much of our hauling fees, which
contribute the largest portion of our
expenses, are already paid or they're or
they're encumbered to be paid. Um, and
because we build trash quarterly, the
third quarter, um, which we're currently
in, was build and mostly paid in June.
So that is showing as payment in June
um, for the third quarter. All right.
And I think I will stop there now.
Thank you for the presentation, Director
Campbell. Um, just one question, uh,
regarding some of the revenue lines, um,
that you mentioned, uh, franchise fees,
parking violations, and pension state
funds. Can you clarify what franchise
fees are and the percentage of parking
violations that get received by the
city?
>> Looking at Larry Cohen, the president of
the parking authority for the last one.
Um, I'm not I actually don't know that
number right off hand. Do you know the
the percentage?
>> Are you asking the percentage or which
fines we're collecting?
>> Um, so I think my understanding is that
uh the city of Langster does not receive
100% of parking tickets, etc. There's a
percentage that's paid out to the city.
>> Yes. So there's an administrative fee
and that is roughly
It's pretty.
>> Do you mind since you're here?
>> Since I'm here.
>> Hi, Larry.
>> Um, would you mind coming to the mic so
the public can who might be watching at
home can um
>> I'll prepare for what I'm supposed to
speak about.
>> That's okay. Oh, yeah. You can sit here.
>> She's eyeballing me back there. Hi. I'm
not here that often. Um,
yeah, the parking as you know
Um the parking authority runs the
violation parking program under a
contract with the city. Parking
authorities is basically like a
management company doing the enforcement
for meters, street sweeping and
residential permit parking. That's what
we're authorized to do for our contract.
For our contract,
parking authority
gets a 10% management fee.
plus our expenses are covered which are
approved in our contract and if there's
any changes to that um allocation of
personnel or whatever we would bring
that to Tina and go through that so if
there's some major change and we need
additional staffing
we would get approval for that and the
city gets 90%
of violation revenue
after expenses
management
It's a pretty good deal for the city.
Um, but it works. We were
nine years into it.
>> Yeah.
>> Two contracts in. Thank you.
>> Does that answer the question?
>> That does. I appreciate the
clarification. Thank you, Larry.
And then uh to your second uh part of
the question, the franchise fees come
from um some agreements that we have
with um actually places like Comcast and
others um that offer services that weize
out, I guess, for lack of a better term.
>> And those line items have been dwindling
over time. Uh and so historically
they've been greater than what they are
now, the franchise fees.
Thank you both. Um, any questions from
the committee or full counsel?
>> Councelor Hurst,
>> thank you. Uh, Director Campbell, that
was a great report. Um, the one question
I had and I know you said that, uh, for
the earned income tax revenue that it
was running about where the city
expected. Um, I just had a question on
the actual like financial statement. It
shows around 27% and so I'm assuming
that the second quarter remittance
probably occurred either this month or
in late July at some point. And is that
kind of what you're saying like as far
as Yeah, it's probably it's coming in
around what expectation is?
>> Yes, exactly. Um that comes in that it
actually came in in July. Um so and it
is about what we expected, but yes,
you're absolutely right. The the quarter
payments for earned income tax are
always the larger payments.
Yes. And so then we would expect to see
that then in the next report.
>> Wonderful. Thank you.
>> Uh thank you councelor Royo and thank
you Director Campbell. This report was
very helpful. Uh my question was
regarding the um unfilled positions and
the vacancies. Um are we planning to
keep those vacancies throughout the rest
of the fiscal year? Um, and given that
we are seeing uh revenues a little bit
ahead of what were anticipated, is there
any um is there any discussions about
bringing some of those positions back um
to kind of uh alleviate some of the
other staff pressures?
>> Sure. Yeah. None of the positions are um
permanently vacant at this point. These
would be vacancies that somebody has
left and we, you know, take a couple
months to fill again. So, it's this uh
kind of eb and flow of of positions, but
none of them are being held as vacant
right now.
>> Uh, thank you. And that concludes my
questions. Thank you, councelor man. Any
additional questions from council?
Right. Any questions from the public.
With that, I'll conclude uh the finance
committee. Thank you, Director Campbell.
Thank you, Council Rayo. Uh, we'll now
go to Community Planning Committee,
Council Craig.
>> Thank you, Council President. Um, we
have one item on the agenda for
community planning this evening, which
is um, administration resolution 55
granting a projection easement to the
Lancaster Parking Authority. And Mr.
Cohen's always has already been up here
and we would appreciate you enlightening
us again.
Okay, if you if you have a whole team,
just
come on. Here
you go.
Larry Cohen, executive director of
parking authority. I'm here with uh our
team for the project.
>> Kelsey Gibson with Maramine Architects.
>> Amanda Gra with Harbor Engineering.
Show the project.
If I can give some history while we're
waiting. How about I do filler?
Um because time is uh precious.
So we used to have an old parking office
at 111
North Prince Street right at the corner
of Prince and Orange right underneath
the parking garage. That was our office
for 40 or 50 years. Uh, no one knew it
was there because there was no signage
until we put that yellow sign to let
people know that the parking authority
office is there. When we took over
enforcement nine years ago, we uh we
basically doubled our staff and we
needed more space. So, we vacated our
old office and entered an agreement to
um buy the community first funds
building, uh which is a fabulous
building, which is a great story of Dan
and I just kind of having a handshake
deal and making it happen. So, we've
been there for the last nine years. It
it serves us well with um our
enforcement program as well as others.
So, over the last nine years, we've kept
the old office vacant.
uh basically land banking it for future
use
uh not knowing what future use was going
to be and then at the nine-year mark it
was like you know what it's time to do
something with this building uh we don't
have that anticipated what the future
use is but we thought it was a great
opportunity for us to give a gift back
to the city and invigorate this part of
the block that laid dormant for many
years um and Part of that vision was
expanding the uh the gallery row area
and um as I said re you know
reinvigorating this part of the block
with a building that'll be a great
retail space for a tenant. And then the
back of the office will will make we'll
bring back our uh parking um
maintenance staff who was in there
before and they're going to have like
the back part of the office. So three4s
of it will be a gallery type of space
and uh offices. So this is a project
that's underway now. The old office has
been torn down and uh looking to bring
this back up. And I'll just highlight
that on the building we um and we've
gone through the sign commission and
such. Uh we put a nice map facade on the
front of the building and uh some
banners to bring some life to that space
as well.
And now I'll turn it over to the
professionals.
>> Thanks, Larry. Uh to add to that, uh the
scope of this project, uh we are
enlarging the uh floor plan or the
existing office building, the footprint
a little bit, and there are interior
renovations. Like Larry said, this is
under construction right now.
The idea here was to bring this uh now
once a office space, now it's going to
be uh tenant space out towards the
street. Give it more of a street
presence. So in our facade that you can
see on this rendering, we have
curtain wall and then a a ventilated
mesh screen above and banner. So it
gives um more life to this facade and
breaks up that mass of the parking
garage.
You can go to the next slide.
So we'll start with the with that we'll
go to the easement portion.
Sure. So I'll just talk a little bit
about the canopy um that is going to be
partially overhanging the right of way
for North Prince Street. Um, so the
second floor of the parking garage right
now is close to the right of way, but
not quite at the right of way. There's
about 1.3 feet between the second floor
of the garage and the right of way. So,
the canopy will get added to the second
floor portion of the garage and then
we'll go out four feet from that. So,
it'll only be overhanging the right of
way by a little over two feet, about two
feet, three inches. And it it does vary
slightly just because the building isn't
100% parallel with the right of way.
And then the canopy is proposed to be
about 17 feet wide and there will be at
least 8 feet clear below the canopy um
where it overhangs the sidewalk. And
again, that will vary slightly just
because of the slope of the sidewalk
away from the building.
Um and then the easement that we're
requesting is slightly larger than the
proposed canopy just to allow for some
um construction in case it's slightly
off. We always like our ements to be
slightly larger. So I think we're at 19
feet wide by three feet
um just under three and a half feet in
depth into the right of way for the
easement area.
Um, so as I mentioned, the canopy is on
the second floor overhang and then the
existing office area is what sits back
from that second floor overhang. So
right now there's
um about 7 feet difference between the
second floor overhang and where the
existing office is. Then with the
building addition, that'll come out not
quite five feet, but the building
addition will still be lower. So that's
where like the canopy isn't very deep
into the right of way, but it's
partially because it's um already
underneath that second floor overhang.
Does that make sense?
>> You want to go to the next slide?
>> Thank you
>> very much. Sounds pretty exciting.
I look forward to seeing it. Are there
any questions from the committee?
>> Thank you, Councelor Craig. Thank you
for the presentation. Um, just one quick
question. I'm assuming this isn't going
to affect any the accessibility of the
sidewalk for pedestrians or anyone like
that based on the type of design it is,
the structure.
>> Great. Thanks. That's all
>> questions from council as a whole.
Yes.
From the public.
Okay. I'll make a motion that we move
resolution 55 to full counsel on the
12th.
>> Second.
>> All those in favor?
>> I
>> I thank you so much.
>> Thank you.
[Music]
>> We do have a tenant, but um we're
leaving it to them. We we we had a lot
of interest in the property which is
great. Shows that there's demand for
space in Gallery Row. Um we're hopeful.
We're gonna leave it to the tenant to do
their official announcement once things
are done. I'd love to steal the thunder,
but
>> let's not do that for them.
>> Entity in the community, so I think
everyone will be really happy. Thank
you.
>> Great.
That was it for community planning,
right? Yep. Great. Thank you very much,
Council Craig. Uh we'll now move to our
public works committee. Councelor
Hirsch.
>> Thank you, Council President. The public
works committee has one item on its
agenda tonight. It's a resolution um
updating uh the city's agreement with
the Lanster County Conservation
District. Um, I'm going to invite
Director Steven Campbell to say a few
words on it. It's mostly administrative
in nature and my understanding is we do
these from time to time. Um, updating
our our memorandum of understanding with
the Lancaster County Conservation
District. So, with that, I'll leave it
to Director Kimmel.
>> Yes, as always, you're very correct in
that preliminary assessment of this
requirement. U, do we have the slides?
Can the slides be brought up?
I just wanted to give a little bit of
background uh about the Lancaster County
Conservation District before we
make the request. Very small summary
while we're waiting for the slide
because it's not really visual. It's
it's just information. The Lancaster
County Conservation District was
established in 1947 and is dedicated to
conserving natural resources and
promoting sustainable practices within
Lancaster County, PA. Some of their key
functions include soil and water
conservation.
And my father, as a matter of fact, was
a member of the U uh USDA, US Department
of Agriculture, and he was an extension
service soil scientist from Penn State.
So I'm very proud of this relationship.
They uh soil and water conservation
works on projects to prevent soil
erosion and manage water resources
effectively. Environmental education
where they provide educational programs
and resources to schools, communities,
and farmers about conservation
practices. Regulatory compliance where
they assist land owners and developers
in complying with environmental
regulations such as erosion and sediment
control. Agricultural support where they
often where they offer technical
assistance and funding opportunities to
farmers to implement conservation
practices and watershed management where
they work on improving the health of
local watersheds through various
initiatives and partnerships.
Is it uh not
like I said there's nothing visual, it's
just words, but it would be nice to have
them.
The city of Lancaster is responsible to
the LCCD for collaboration, which is
working together on projects that impact
both the city and the county, such as
storm water management and urban
conservation efforts. compliance, which
is ensuring that city projects comply
with the environmental regulations and
guidelines set forth by LCCD.
Support, meaning providing support for
LCCD initiatives which may include
funding, resources or participation in
educational programs. And also last but
not least, community engagement,
encouraging residents and businesses
within the city to participate in
conservation programs and practices
promoted by the LCCD.
Keep it on this slide.
Thisou outlines the partnership between
L the Lancaster County Conservation
District and the city and defines their
common areas of responsibility serving
the citizens of the city of Lancaster.
Common areas of responsibility include
en erosion and sediment pollution
control for storm water discharges
associated with construction activities,
minimum control measures outlined in the
city's MS4 or municipal separate storm
sewer system general permit and
education and outreach for the public.
Next slide.
Resolution number 54-2025
includes minor updates to the
existingou.
The updates include minor wording and
punctuation updates throughout. So it's
very very minor.
An update to allow the LCCD to provide
documents electronically and on its
website. A novel approach.
The Lancaster County Conservation
District has also included an update to
decrease its plan review and permitting
timeline for applications and erosion
and sediment control plans from 10 days
to 5 days, as well as an update for the
LCCD to reduce its inspection and
inspection response timelines from 10
days to 8 days. The LCCCD inspects earth
disturbance activities to ensure that
the implementation and maintenance of
the ENS plan and chapter 92 ENS
practices.
There's no proposed change to the m to
the municipal responsibilities outlined
in theou.
So as described, this is very much an
administrative change, but the the the
uh document or the agreement that was in
place as of May of 2024
ceases and the mo and is replaced by
thisou. So all terms all terms and
conditions except for the change in
technology and deliverance and the
timelines remains the same and all other
responsibilities remain the same.
>> Thank you Director Campbell. Um any
questions or comments from the public
works committee? If I may scout ideas
>> in relations to our new um AI coreware
that's going to be in basically
implemented into our city and also
partially lane peter um township. Will
they also provide us updates on how much
water, how much electricity
um that's going to be used to the
public.
As with everything, um the the regular
reporting for any use, any activity
continues. So this would be fully fully
consistent with any other reporting
mechanisms that are already underway.
>> Thank you.
>> And if I could just add to that to say
that the former use of LSC was consuming
more water than the proposed new use. Uh
and so I just want to make sure that
everybody's aware of that.
Um and as it relates to um the
electricity usage um that is really an
issue for the Pennsylvania Utilities
Commission which regulates um issues
related to electricity. And I would
remind council that we are part of a
13-st state consortium that um is a
wholesale retailer called PJM and um
would direct your attention to recent
activities by the Shapiro administration
to address those rates and that really
functions outside of this body.
Any other uh comments or questions uh
from the public works committee
or council as a whole?
Any questions or comments from the
public?
And if you don't mind, if you could just
state your name and block our residence
as well
>> for the meeting record.
[Music]
>> All right. Taylor Raymond, 500 block of
St. Joseph Street. Um, I just wanted
some clarification on the reduced
timelines. You said from uh 10 days to 5
days for one of them and 10 to 8 for
another. Is that calendar days or
business days?
That is a very good question. I believe
that it is. Hold on a second.
I can confirm for you. Um,
but I believe that it is calendar days.
Any other questions or comments from the
public?
Uh, hearing none, I would make a motion
to move resolution 54 uh to our full
meeting of council on August 12th,
tomorrow night.
>> All those in favor?
>> I
struggling with this mic. That concludes
the public works committee.
>> That's all right. Thank you very much,
council hir. Um and then finally this
evening we have public safety committee
council Diaz.
>> Thank you council president. Uh public
safety committee um has a bill number
052025 creating a community police
review board. Um due to the scheduling
issues with the meeting and I personally
prefer to move this proposal to the
September meeting um now that it is
online and can be reviewed. Plus, I also
would like to hear back from um the
chief of police um Chief Mendes um if he
has any um questions or anything that he
would like to add to this. Um it's
really important also that the committee
responds. Um and also the mayor to see
what we can do for our community since
we're continually getting requests for
it.
Council Diaz, is your wish to not take
this up under your committee this
evening?
>> Not this evening.
>> Mr. Harris, does this need to be tabled?
As our parliamentarian, I want to check
and make sure um if it needs to be
tabled or if it can simply not be taken
up by the committee.
>> I'm sorry. I think it's simply not be
taken up. There's no action. No action
taken by the committee.
>> Okay. Thank you very much, Councelor
Diaz. Appreciate that.
Here
we go. Um, so you we don't need to take
that up onto your committee. Um, and you
have no other items. Is that correct?
That is correct. Thank you.
>> Sounds good. Thank you very much. Um,
then counselors, we have reached the
conclusion of our committee meeting
agendas this evening. Mr. Harris has
submitted his clerk's report in writing
to us. Thank you very much for that. So,
that is on the record. Um, having
reached the end of our uh agenda, I will
hear a motion to adjurnn.
>> Motion to adjurnn. Second. All in favor?
>> I I thank you. We arejourned.